hi my name is Rohith ponse and today i'm
going to be giving the presentation on
using machine learning to diagnose
pneumonia
hello my name is Rohith ponse and today
I'll be talking to you about how I use
machine learning to diagnose pneumonia
from chest x-rays so a little bit about
myself I'm a junior at Nika Valley High
School in Naperville Illinois I'm
involved in several extracurricular
activities including speech team youth
in government wild scats which is a
local jazz group Maui leadership command
computing Club over the summer I did an
internship at Northwestern where I
worked with a neuroscience PhD student I
designed fMRI stimuli for her experiment
which analyzed fMRI images for mobility
in stroke patients I also solved some
hardware compatibility issues and
performed some basic data analysis on
optic fiber glove sensor data and
created several manuals and video guides
in auditioning to interning at
Northwestern I also attended the wolfram
high school summer camp in welcome
Massachusetts where I worked on the
project I'm gonna be telling you about
today so today I'll take you through the
process through which I created my
project before I continue I'd like to
thank my mentor Michael Kaminski for
helping guide me in addition I would
like to thank other mentors such as Rick
Harrigan Andrea Griffin Douglas Smith
and Greg Hurst for helping me finally
I'd like to thank my parents for
encouraging me to pursue my passions and
keep learning so here's some background
information pneumonia is an infection
that causes inflammation in one or both
of the lungs bacteria viruses and fungi
are all organisms that cause pneumonia
bacterial pneumonia is the most common
type and is caused by bacteria that
multiplies in the lungs viola pneumonia
is caused by an array of viruses the
most common one being influenza
although the severity of pneumonia can
very young children seniors and people
with weakened immune systems are the
most vulnerable the CDC reports that 1
million people are hospitalized due to
pneumonia every year and unfortunately
50,000 people die from this infection
every year
early and proper diagnosis is key to
decreasing the mortality rate of a
patient conventional diagnosis methods
that like solely examining a patient's
medical history or symptoms have their
shortcomings and other methods like
blood tests pulse oximetry tests which
look at blood oxygen levels and the
bottom tests are more invasive but get
the job done
chest x-rays have long been an efficient
and reliable Diagnostics tool for
pneumonia
although these tools are reliable human
error can play a huge role in the proper
diagnosis and hence the well-being of a
patient in fact Dutch researchers who
published their findings in the European
respiratory journal found that of 140
patients who had that pneumonia
diagnosed by x-ray certified doctors
initially thought only 41 of them had
the severe lung infection my project
uses a convolutional neural network to
diagnose the type of pneumonia that a
patient has and the location of the
pneumonia to reduce this margin of error
with doctors since pneumonia is an
airspace disease patients air spaces are
filled with bacteria viruses pus and
other microorganisms a diagnosis is
determined by infiltrates or white spots
the loss of diaphragmatic shadows and
evidence of pulmonary consolidation or
areas of the lung that I filled with
liquid instead of air I use transfer
learning with my neural network transfer
learning is defined by the book deep
learning as the situation where what has
been learned in one setting is exploited
to improve generalization in another
setting essentially what this means is
that a pre trained neural network is
used as a starting point for a second
task
I used ResNet 50 an architecture that
was released in 2015 by Microsoft
Research Asia this network was
originally trained on 1.2 million images
with a thousand classes the immense
computing power time and resources and
knowledge dedicating to perfect this
network made it a great
neural network for transfer learning
here's an example of ResNet 50 in action
it correctly predicts that this image is
a golden retriever as you can see I set
the program to give me the top 10
probabilities of what it thought the
image was there are two notable layers
in this network the linear layer and the
softmax layer first the linear layer
maps the features processed by the other
layers to the classifications given
classifications or classes are the
different objects the neural network is
trained to recognize in the standard
Reds is net case the classes are the
thousand different objects in the case
of my project my linear layer will be
trained to recognize a normal chest
x-ray one with bacterial pneumonia and
one with viral pneumonia second the
softmax layer determines the
probabilities of what the image is again
here we see the probabilities of what
the neural net thought the golden
retriever was the top results are golden
retriever with 42 percent red bone with
28 percent Irish Setter at 8% clearly
the golden retrievers classification was
the highest the neural net so the neural
net thought who is a golden retriever
here
I removed the linear and softmax layers
these layers are currently configured to
recognize a thousand classes and I only
need them to recognize three classes of
information normal bacterial pneumonia
and viral pneumonia I will add these two
layers later on below here I replace the
input layer to receive an input of image
dimensions 512 pixels by 512 pixels I
will configure my training images to be
at this size next I added three layers
to the neural net the resized net here
will extract features from the data set
this new neural net called learn net
will be used to interpret the features
and output what it thinks the input
image is the three layers I will do this
are the linear net and soft max layer
that I explained earlier and the drop
out layer the drop out layer is a
component of the neural network that
prevents code
patience of neural-net by randomly
dropping out layers when training the
net this is a crucial part of the neural
network because it's used to help the
network improve its accuracy and reduce
overfitting or the tendency of a neural
network to be extremely specialized to a
limited set of data points in other
words this neural net becomes very good
at recognizing images in the data set
that you've given it to learn with
overfitting is not desirable because it
makes the neural network very
inefficient on data points outside of
the training set additionally I
specified the output as 0 1 or 2 0 means
a normal chest x-ray
one means viral pneumonia and two means
bacterial pneumonia to recap the linear
layer made the features from the above
layers map the features from the above
layers to the 3 classes and the soft mac
layer determines the probabilities of
these features and the drop out layer is
used to help reduce overfitting the
kaggle dataset that I used had over
5,000 images when I downloaded it to my
computer I imported the files from their
respective folders here the virus and
bacterial pneumonia files were found in
the same folder so I used a simple
separating sort tool to organize only
the images of a certain class to their
corresponding variables I conformed the
images to have dimensions of 512 by 512
I did this because I specified in the
input layer to take images of only those
dimensions later adjusted the way I
conformed my images by augmenting the
data set to improve my neural net by
altering the data set my neural net
would become adapted to a greater
variety of images I made 40% of the
images undergo a rotation via rotate
image and I made another 40% of the
images undergo a perspective
transformation via sheer image an
important idea to consider is that your
neural net is only as good as the data
that you feed it by augmenting the data
one can prevent the neural net from
learning irrelevant patterns and thereby
improve the accuracy here you can see a
sample effect of the random
transformations and its effect on the
images
so here two separate neural networks are
created one the recess net extracts
features or processes the image using
the neural net to obtain some key
information about the image the other
the learn net which has the linear
softmax and drop out layer interprets
the features and determines the output
by creating two separate neural networks
we can process we can pre-process the
data instead of processing the data
repeatedly as we would have to do if the
resize net and the learned net were
combined here the feature attracted
images undergo two processes first the
images are mapped to certain numerical
codes normal chest x-rays are mapped to
code 0 fire stress x-rays are mapped to
the code 1 and bacteria chest x-rays are
mapped to the code 2
the images are mapped to the codes so
the neural network knows the identity of
the images when training the network in
addition the codes are used when the
train network is given an image and
determines a diagnosis for example if
the train network is given a normal
chest x-ray then it should output the
code 0 after mapping the images to the
codes the process images are set the
process images are combined into one
massive list which are partitioned into
a training set and a test set the
training set will train the network and
determine the proper weights needed to
recognize the images properly the test
set will be used to check the true
progress of the neural network since the
neural net is never trained on the test
set it would serve as an objective
indicator of the progress of the
accuracy of the neural net finally after
the data was pre processed and had its
features attracted I was able to train
my neural net I trained the neural net
network four separate times each with
different settings and each had
different accuracies the regular data
set with 35 runs of training had the
regular data set with 35 runs of
training had an accuracy of about 24.9%
the regular data set with 70 runs of
training had an accuracy of about
nineteen point nine percent and the
augmented data set with
thirty-five rounds of training had an
accuracy about twenty point nine percent
and the Augmented data set with seventy
runs of training had an accuracy of
about seventeen point four percent below
is an image of a loss function and the
error rate for the Augmented seventy
round neural net I use this neural net
in the final product because it was the
most accurate you can see that there's a
graph of the error rate for the training
set and the testing set and there's
something called loss function a loss
function is a way of evaluating how well
your Aguilar your algorithm models your
data set after the neural network was
done training I exported all the files
for use on the microsite now I'll talk
about the second part of my experiment
determining the location of the
pneumonia for separate neural networks
were created to determine the location
of the pneumonia left virus right virus
left bacteria and right bacteria i
evaluated the left lobe images separate
from the right lobe images because the
heart is visible as a white blob much
like a pulmonary consolidation on the
chest x-ray the neural net could butcher
the diagnosis if the lobes were combined
evaluating the lobe separately for each
type of pneumonia helped ensure the
accuracy in location recognition for the
pneumonia location detection part of
this project a subset of the data was
created hundred images of the left lobe
normal and the right lobe normal each
and hundreds of minutes of the left lobe
virus right low virus left lobe
bacterial right low bacterial pneumonia
each were selected to Train four
separate neural networks to help
determine the location of the pneumonia
here are the statements I used to import
the unedited chest x-rays here are the
functions which were used to edit the
images with resize and crop resize crop
finder both are used in conjunction to
crop the image with the number of black
pixels on both sides of the image are
found at five separate places the
greatest amount of pixels for both sides
are used to crop the image these
functions were useful because it almost
always placed the spinal cord in the
center
and as a result the images could be
correctly cut and interpreted by the
neural network after using this method
that I created to edit the images this
function was used to separate the images
into halves if a certain image was in
the left lobe virus data set only the
left side was extracted these operations
were performed on all of the groups of
the data the ResNet 50 neural net was
used for transfer learning with a
similar setup to the neural network
created in the main diagnosis a half
cleft net was created with the drop out
layer linear layer softmax layer and
output of two classes the outputs were 0
and 1 0 meaning that the chest x-ray
given has a normal normal diagnosis
which means no pneumonia and 1 meaning
that the lungs had pneumonia this
sequence of steps was used for all the
other 4 networks the Train files were
exported for use on the microsite here
are the error rates for the location
detection in neural networks so virus
left us about 5% virus right was about
5% bacteria left was about 0% and
bacteria right was about 15% it can
easily be determined from the size of
the data set and the results that the
neural nets over fitted to the data
increasing the actual accuracy of the
neural nets is a project I intend to
complete using the exported neural Nets
I created a microsite that looks like
the following so it takes an input of a
chest x-ray and gives you the diagnosis
of which type of pneumonia it is and if
like which side which lobe its present
in I also simulated a real use case of
my program by taking a picture of the
x-ray from my computer screen like
someone would take a picture of the
chest act like someone would take a
physical picture of a test x-ray I
uploaded the image to my program and
found some success so to conclude I
created a transfer learning neural
network which successfully diagnosed
pneumonia with an accuracy of about
3% and accurately detected the location
of pneumonia with an average accuracy
about 93% data editing and augmentation
procedures and increasing the amount of
training rounds helped increase the
accuracy of diagnosis currently two
other wolfram highschool camp campers
and I have made a team for a cago
competition by the Radiological Society
of North America we hope to place among
the top teams and learn more about
machine learning while we're at it some
future improvements include improving
the image formatting function to make
the current program more compatible with
poor quality chest x-rays also thermal
images have proven to be a crude means
of diagnosing pneumonia using a similar
neural network setup except with thermal
images to diagnose pneumonia would be a
useful tool for someone who for someone
who doesn't have access to a chest
x-rays also further data augmentation to
improve accuracy of the neural network
could prove to be beneficial using a
patient's history as well as image
analysis to offer a more holistic
diagnosis is also project that I'm
considering undertaking thank you for
listening do you guys have any questions
you